la famille de joanna parrish je viens de
rencontrer la juge en charge du dossier
28 ans presque jour pour jour après le
meurtre de leur fille les parents sont
désormais quasiment certain il y aura
bien un procès pour juger michel
fourniret
évidemment c'est un soulagement
je ne peux pas parler de bonheur bien
sûr mais rendez vous compte
ça fait quand même 28 ans que nous
voulons ici en france c'est très long le
corps de joanna parrish avait été
retrouvé le 17 mai 1990 sur les bords de
l'yonne
le mystère autour de la mort de cette
jeune britannique va demeurer jusqu'en
2005 jusqu aux aveux de monique olivier
la femme du tueur en série michel
fourniret elle accuse son mari qui a nié
en bloc pendant 13 ans jusqu'en février
dernier
aujourd'hui les éléments du dossier sont
accablants pour le couple fourniret et
monique olivier est passée par quatre
fois aux aveux en donnant des détails
très précis
michel fourniret entendu à six reprises
par le juge dit qu' elles sont mortes
parce qu'elles l'ont croisé enfin que
donc voilà des éléments évidemment tout
à fait important et puis on a maintenant
la certitude que michel fourniret était
à auxerre dans cette période là
lors du procès va donc enfin sonné 28
ans après les faits je pense que les
choses auraient pu aller bien plus vite
sûrement dans les premiers jours michel
fourniret et c'est un psychopathe
quelqu'un de très vicieux la brasse
beaucoup de victimes
c'était peut-être possible de le
confondre
plus tôt la juge d'instruction devrait
prochainement écoute et monique olivier
la partenaire de crimes du tueur en
série ensuite il faudra attendre au
moins jusqu'à la fin de l'année 2019 ou
que s'ouvre enfin le procès